haustiere sind keine kuscheltiere sagt
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin julia
klöckner und will jetzt ein gassi gesetz
einführen
demnach soll jeder hundebesitzer
mindestens zweimal am tag mit seinem
schützling rausgehen müssen
das klingt erstmal gut aber die ist
dieses gesetz auch tatsächlich sinnvoll
wir haben uns einmal bei hundebesitzern
in deutschland umgehört was sie davon
halten würden
wenn man ein tier liebt ehrlich gesagt
eine selbstverständlichkeit erfreulich
auch keine regelung dafür also dass das
kommt von dem gefühl her von selber dass
man das auch will man er hier speziell
der thema glück gehabt ist in kurzform
kroner zu uns gekommen und durch den
lock down war ich dann praktisch den
ganzen tag hier also er hat mehr als
vier stunden gehabt er den ganzen tag
gehabt
viele menschen wissen die leute genommen
einfach ein anderes sehen sie das macht
er jetzt gerade wasser sein will mein
kleiner park kultury
ich halte davon gar nicht mehr zu
benutzen von einer reglementierung
letzten endes ja jeder finden
unser heil dabei fanden sie noch davon
ausgehen soll
jan über dieses mögliche gassi gesetz
möchte ich jetzt noch etwas mehr
diskutieren mir nun zugeschaltet udo
kopernik vom verband für das deutsche
hundewesen guten morgen sagen sie mir
was würden sie von diesem gesetz halten
ist das sinnvoll
also die tierschutz hundeverordnung gibt
es ja schon sehr lange das ist jetzt
nichts neues jetzt sind änderungen hält
geplant dass man sich ausreichend um und
kümmert das stand da schon immer drin
und jetzt wird eben präzisiert in diesem
auslauf zweimal täglich insgesamt
mindestens eine stunde für viele hunde
ist das sogar zu wenig wie genau sollte
man das denn dann überhaupt
kontrollieren
generell die zwei stunden am tag sie
sagen gerade ist es für manche schon zu
wenig aber es gibt rund acht millionen
hunde in deutschland könnte man da
überhaupt hinterherkommen also das ist
will es jetzt auf den einzelnen
unterhalter herunter gebrochen würde
überhaupt nicht zu leisten
zuständig sind dafür die amtsveterinär
in den kreisen und kreisfreien städten
die auch schon genug aufgaben mit der
lebensmittelüberwachung und auch andere
wichtige aufgaben im tierschutz wenn man
die nutztiere denkt also die können
jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen der
unterhalter soll jetzt so ein
fahrtenbuch für seinen und führen
und einmal im monat wird das
kontrolliert aber ich denke auch darauf
zielt das gesetz gar nicht sondern es
richtet sich ja hier auch speziell an
die nicht an den hundehalter sondern die
ziele und da sind ja gott sei dank die
wenigsten runde von getroffen und da
wäre eben der gesetzgeber sicherstellen
dass auch diese und eben entsprechenden
auslauf haben und da ist die eine stunde
eigentlich schon knapp kennen sie einmal
kurz für uns deutlicher machen was genau
die zwingerhaltung ist ja zwingerhaltung
ist wenn wir zum beispiel ins tierheim
geht dann sieht man in den zwingern da
geht es gar nicht anders
dass hunde sind
angenommen in käfigen gehalten und es
ist auch in dieser tierschutz
hundeverordnung eben geregelt wie groß
das dann sein muss und welchen freier
auslauf da noch zur verfügung stehen hat
und darüber hinaus der wurden der will
ja auch eben entsprechende umweltreize
wahrnehmen muss eben auch gewährleistet
sein dass die hunde zweimal am tag
ausgeführt werden für insgesamt eine
stunde und das ist schon eigentlich eine
minimalforderung ganz ja auch eben
gehört von den unterhalter viele hunde
die haben eben viel höhere ansprüche die
wollen auch beschäftigt wären die wollen
ja nicht nur spazieren gehen sondern die
wollen auch was tun
und das hier ist eben wirklich schon
eine minimalforderung den meisten runden
wurde das gar nicht genügen ist denn da
eine faustregel diese hundebesitzer mit
geben können oder vielleicht auch
denjenigen die noch welche werden wollen
ab einer bestimmten größe muss man so
lange raus oder wie weiß man was der
eigene hund wirklich braucht also ein
hundehalter der mission vertraut ist er
wird das merken wer sich jetzt erst ein
hund anschafft den empfehle ich besuchen
sie einen seriösen züchter oder ein
seriöses tierheim da werden sie
entsprechend beraten welche bedürfnisse
der und für den sie sich interessieren
hat ein border collie also wohnt der
viel arbeiten will oder eurem boxer der
braucht viel viel mehr auslauf als jetzt
weiß ich ein kleiner markt ära oder
entschied aber das ist sehr rasse
spezifisch wir haben in deutschland fast
250 verschiedene rassen die rundung
unterscheiden sich nicht nur in der
größe sondern auch in dem was sie im
kopf leisten und dementsprechend sind
auch die haltungs anforderungen
unterschiedlich und da lässt man sich am
besten vom experten beraten meinetwegen
auch von unerfahrenen trainer oder unter
trainerin oder eben auch vom tierarzt